another item in the sort of good thing
it was a long weekend and lots of
Americans weren't watching the news
category is that Donald Trump tweeted
out a classified image containing
sensitive military intelligence Trump
tweeted this on Friday it was a picture
from a classified intelligence briefing
in which he's basically taunting Iran
over nuclear technology and over a
failed rocket launch saying quote
alongside the picture he tweeted the
United States of America was not
involved in the catastrophic accident
during final launch preparation
preparations for the saffir SLV launched
at Semin launch site one in Iran I wish
Iran best wishes and good luck in
determining what happened at site one
and as you can see the tweet went with a
picture a satellite image and there's
more information on the image about what
things are it's a detailed picture there
is you know signs pointing to a damage
support vehicle a damaged gantry service
tower and this was an image from a
classified secure intelligence briefing
that the president received that's how
those images are labeled this was a
classified satellite surveillance image
and it was very easily
amateurs were able to take this image
that Trump tweeted and sort of go
backwards reverse engineer that it came
from a particular American satellite USA
224 now the fact that we even have this
satellite and that these are the types
of images it can produce and that it was
at a particular location at a particular
point in time that in and of itself is
already sensitive information one of the
things that's important in the world of
classified information is that you don't
want other countries to know what
technology we do and don't have and how
are we deploying it by publishing this
image Donald Trump is not only
publishing classified contents right the
content of the picture itself is from a
classified briefing but he's exposing to
China to Russia to whoever else the
exact capabilities of the satellite used
to take the picture and its location
Trump is
taking a legalistic approach and so are
his followers saying I we had a photo
and I released it said Donald Trump
which I have the absolute right to do
because that's true he's the president
he can declassify anything he wants
anything that's classified that the
president publishes is sort of de facto
Declassified and that's something that
he's allowed to do that's not the
important conversation in fact that
conversation is a total red herring the
question is not is Trump going to go to
prison for tweeting this even though by
the way people have gone to prison for a
distributed images that were gathered by
these exact satellites the issue is this
Trump understand what he's doing does
Trump endanger the national security of
the United States by tweeting this is it
advantageous to be tweeting this in any
geopolitical national security or
intelligence sense and the answer to all
of these questions is obviously no Iran
had a failed rocket launch there are
defenders saying a picture had already
been made public before Donald Trump
tweeted this Donald Trump tweeted a far
higher resolution image with great
detail which exposes much more
specifically the satellites that we have
are using and their capabilities Trump
is doing it to try to taunt Iran and in
so doing he's proving himself to be
stunningly careless with classified
information which is not a shock this is
actually a trend remember when Donald
Trump was in the Oval Office he was
visited by a couple of Russians
including a Russian spy recruiter Sergei
something I believe it was Sergey Kiss
lyac and Donald Trump in order to appear
like the big man he spilled secrets to
the Russian spy recruiter that we got
from our ally Israel and of course then
Israel had to say wait a sec maybe we
have to be more careful in telling the
United States the information that we
have because Donald Trump thinks only in
terms of what will make him look like a
big strong boy the big boy the powerful
boy on the playground that everybody
defers to it's not about what's good for
us it's not about what's good for others
it's not about what's good for
relationships or geopolitics or whatever
else remember that the right went crazy
warning us Hillary can't be trusted
he'll
his emails Hillary's email server she's
terrible with email and classified this
in that and the exact same people who
told us Hillary can't be trusted the
same people who fell for that are
defending Donald Trump on this there are
people who have gone to prison for
leaking pictures from satellites like
this one again it's this is the USA two
to four satellite it's a kh-11 type
satellite and Donald Trump's defenders
are not only defending this they're
gleefully defending Trump doing it if
you're a foreign adversary you can
actually work backwards from this image
to figure out given that these are the
capabilities of the United States
satellite how can we organize ourselves
to hide things we are doing from
satellites like this one once you
understand the resolution and the
capabilities of this satellite and the
way in which it works you can then start
to work around the capabilities of this
satellite this is the height of some
combination of and you tell me what
proportions it's easy at each of these
things this is a combination of
arrogance ignorance delusions of
grandeur narcissism cognitive decline
complete lack of responsibility and
complete carelessness with sensitive and
classified information and to some
degree of just being a bad person who is
using all of the elements of the
presidency not just deciding where Mike
Pence will stay when he goes to Ireland
so that you can make money off of them
I'll tell you about that later in the
show but also using the intelligence
community and using classified
information and using things like our
satellites to try to taunt other
countries and appear like the big man on
campus let me know what you think let me
know your reaction to all of this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and
remember that we are now streaming live
on Twitter on twitch at twitch.tv slash
David Pakman remember that twitch prime
subscriptions don't renew automatically
each month many hundreds of you signed
up for a twitch Prime subscription for
free if you have Amazon Prime last month
we're now in September those have
expired
go back to twitch.tv it takes 30 seconds
subscribe to twitch.tv slash david
pakman with twitch prime it costs you
nothing and it counts as a paid
subscription for us it's great to be
back a lot to discuss after the long
holiday weekend here in the US and much
more of that coming up right after the
break